so now what we're dealing with is we
have this report whistleblowers claiming
the FBI's been purging conservative
agents okay is that right that's we that
that was it's reported that several
whistleblowers came out and said people
who are conservative are being called
disloyal and they're being removed
you take a look at the GOP front runner
in Michigan getting arrested and charged
on several misdemeanors but the FBI
raids his house that's right and then
they dragged him out of there they drag
them out so any way you cut it the
federal government is now arresting
opponents of the Democrats of the
Democrats and it is a Democrat
Administration basically criminally
Prosecuting and targeting its Rivals
meanwhile you have people terrorists who
are who are showing up to the homes of
justices
with no accountability someone literally
came out to kill Kavanaugh and Merrick
Garland still will do nothing because I
mean let's be real they're into it Merit
Garland and the protesters are the same
they want it to happen jenseki said we
encourage this yeah and then the Dude
shows up Lori Lightfoot called people to
Arms that's right literally over over
what was happening with Roe v Wade in
this league and this guy wasn't it like
May 9th or something yeah she said it's
a call to arms and we must fight for our
rights and we will not allow it and then
this guy he heard it apparently and then
he shows up
fortunately he turned himself in we're
very very fortunate the guy had a Moment
of clarity to be like okay this is this
is crazy
but this is what happens when they
incite they encourage and then they
don't hold they don't enforce the law
I would say
the the federal government's
unwillingness to enforce the law here is
in I would I would say is if they are
involved themselves in stochastic
terrorism you know what's interesting
though too is what his stochastic
terrorism it's when you say things like
we certainly encourage people to show up
and protest in front of these people's
houses and then someone shows up with
weapons to kill the person who lives
there so it's kind of like oh won't
someone rid me of this priest and then
someone goes and kills the prince I
never said to do it I was speaking
rhetorically Charles Manson apparently
that's how he uh was like sure be great
if some people showed up at their house
and wreaked havoc or whatever he told
and then texts and the rest of them went
to the house and killed a bunch of
people Manson was like I never told him
to do it yeah you kind of insinuated
that maybe they should so when jensaki
encourages them to do it Lori Lightfoot
says Call to Arms literally and then the
guide shows up and then Merit Garland
okay this one guy is getting charged
right that's their line actually trying
to pull it off but the people who are
protesting in front of the homes they're
they're committing a federal crime
and the federal government's like no no
that's fine we want
hyper partisan pressure applied to the
courts we that that's the reason why you
can't do this is that there can be no
justice unless the courts can function
that's why we have the rule the law in
the first place this is actually the the
legal justification
if you can't have courts be free from
political pressures then you can't
actually have Justice no then there's no
justice at all which is why we said no
protesting to sway a Court's opinion
Sheamus brought this up the other day
judges are not elected officials right
they're appointed I mean some judges are
actually but these these federal judges
are appointed so you're not going to
change if they're if they're going to be
in office or not what you're trying to
do is force them to give the ruling in
your favor which is not Justice
and that and the and Merrick Garland the
federal government Biden's
Administration the doj they are they are
in favor of all of this but if you look
at even what what happened in Virginia
right so we had protests outside John
Robert's house chief justice and there
was a recent election in Virginia
everyone thought it was really going to
shake things up Glenn Younkin
conservative came in to lead Virginia
and he didn't do anything about the
protesters outside Robert's house he
posted on Twitter that he was monitoring
the situation and it's like no like at
you know as my friend Jack posobic said
it was like no the rest of us are
watching what's going on you're supposed
to actually do something you're the
leader of this state it is a federal law
though I'm not sure there's a state law
prohibiting them from doing it so they
don't have the jurisdiction oh is that
right that's my understanding I could be
wrong though yeah the idea is that
Merrick garland would be the one who
would have to say this is a federal law
that you're breaking and have to go in
you'd think after someone showed up to
kill the guy he'd be like okay okay okay
okay we're gonna get people out of here
right no so I I'm just telling you
January six hearings nothing on May 29th
it was a total it's a total show trial
it's Preposterous and that they brought
in daytime TV Guide to like do the
production on it prime time they I
thought it was a good morning America
guy it's an ABC a former president of
ABC news is that yeah
um they probably did Good Morning
America yeah I think he did but it's
just so ridiculous it's so obvious and
transparent what they're doing they're
propagandizing this entire thing just to
try and make it so that Trump can't run
again and so that all conservatives are
vilified as white supremacists well the
reality is conservatives don't care that
a bunch of leftists tried burning down
the White House and forced the president
into a bunker I mean you can argue no of
course they care yeah but they don't
care nearly as much as the left does the
left doesn't want to talk about how they
actually set fire to St John's Church
and a White House White House guard post
and tried ripping down the barricades
and they did ripped on them they did but
I mean like the actual they wanted to
actually breach the White House
150 officers were injured in that
and conservatives don't bring it up the
right I mean I I hate saying
conservatives but
every single person in opposition to the
violence yeah we can sit here and be
like yeah antifa's gone too far but
we're not funding hearings there's no
conservative right-wing libertarian
moderate millionaires or billionaires
being like we need to get all these
politicians to do Prime Time hearings
about what happened on May 29th when the
president was forced in the bunker by a
bunch of far-left extremists and it
never happens that's just one example of
what the right is never willing to do
meanwhile the left won't shut up a
right-wing dude can fart in an elevator
in you know next to a senator and
they're screaming
people in pink hats storm the Supreme
Court they go to the Supreme Court
they're banging on the doors and they're
screaming they show up to the Senate
buildings and they're on every floor
screaming and they shut it down that's
not an Insurrection they go to the White
House and set fire to a church nearly
burning it down it's called the
president's Church they they set fire to
the guard posters I mentioned they tore
it on the barricades and tried breaching
the fence 150 officers harmed the left
doesn't care and apparently the right
doesn't either so long as regular people
are caught between a news cycle showing
constant images of violent Maga people
and the right just keeps saying no no no
well then the only thing regular people
are going to see is the right wing being
violent what do you think they should do
uh I think people on the right should
have been having hearings on May 29
endlessly I think the first thing they
should do in uh once they're all sworn
into Congress on January 3rd is they're
gonna they should impeach Joe Biden and
they should have hearings on Ukraine and
barisma and the and the private Equity
deals in China and they should hold
hearings on 529 and they should say 529
529 over and over and over again never
shut up about it
that's brilliant and then here's what
happens you know what I do I'm sitting
in I'm sitting in the Congressional
hearing and they say we'd like to have a
conversation to with you about this uh
big Tech social media policy and I would
say thank you for the question on May
29th far left extremists set fire to a
church outside of the White House and
they've reached the barricades injuring
150 police officers and they force that
sir sir we're talking about big tech oh
I'm sorry yes so as I was saying on 5 29
that's what they're doing yeah that is
what they're doing and I've got I I you
know they're posting memes they are
going nuts now I'll say it's the economy
stupid they can try and do everything
they want I don't think it's going to
save them but it's certainly when it
comes to the political violence and the
escalation of the culture War the right
never never stands up and says this is
the subject the news cycle is always
being set by The Establishment well
we're always just reacting we're always
just reacting to what they're doing 5
29.
well it was interesting too um they
talked about that whole wasn't that the
wasn't that when they kept insisting
that Trump had gone over to the
president's Church specifically for a
photo op and they were complaining that
protesters had been unlawfully cleared
from that Park that was the big story
from 529 and when Trump was forced into
the emergency bunker they mocked him for
it that's right they laughed they said
it was funny the Republicans uh so so
the Senate Republicans are mostly just
establishment chills who are like better
keep my head down and not get involved
that we can take power back and um you
know there's relatively few actual good
politicians period right but I think
for one
it's going to be really interesting next
year because Republicans aren't going to
they're not gonna have a veto proof
majority and they're not they they can
they can nuke the filibuster but Joe
Biden can still veto I think they should
just scream 529.
529 the Insurrection yeah but the
Insurrection on 529 Luke you you expect
the Republicans to do something and no I
don't and they don't do nothing right
um and what better way to kind of low
people into this kind of uh server to it
this kind of larger enslavement than
having these these people up there who
talk a good game but don't really do
anything and and again when you look at
a lot of the things that that's been
happening you know a lot of people like
to blame only the Democrats no the
Republicans also are hand in hand
working together not serving the
interests of the general public not
helping the people out there not going
out of their way to actually serve their
representatives they serve the special
interest and if they gain power which
they most likely will you could expect
the same shenanigans that are going to
screw you over but instead of being
screwed over up by the left side you're
going to be screwed over on the right
side so I don't have any hope this is
just my own political kind of ideology
from what I've seen within the past 15
years because it's it's kind of
sickening seeing this kind of Left Right
divide and conquer game and nothing get
achieved nothing get done and none of
these parties actually truly address the
issues that are affecting the general
public they always talk about emotional
hyperbolic issues they always change the
conversation and we never get to the
core issue of why we are being screwed
over every single day well I think one
thing that happened with the Republicans
too is they spent a long time just
worrying about you know fiscal Iraq
Afghanistan you know fiscal tax issues
things like that you know they thought
that they were above all of this other
stuff a lot of conservatives that I knew
um you know growing up or over the last
several years uh prior to this current
cultural moment were very insistent that
they were fiscally conservative and
socially liberal and I think that was a
big mistake you know I think giving up
the culture and saying whatever crazy
stuff you want to do the culture is fine
you want to destroy the foundations of
American principles that's fine you want
to say that all the founding fathers
were racist that's fine you want to tear
down Confederate statues that's fine
right you want to say that the
Declaration of Independence was just
racist that's fine we're just gonna deal
with tax law that was a really huge and
stupid mistake because it gave
everything away it said the thing that
we're fighting for is meaningless anyway
so what's the point of doing it you know
what is it that we are going out there
and dealing with I was at a conference
recently TP USA this young women's
Leadership Summit and I was on a panel
talking about some stuff and it was
really fascinating the most fascinating
part were the questions so you had all
of these thousands of women there young
women who
um
who are really really insistent that
it's time to take back the culture time
to go for it time and they're angry and
they're really pissed off one young
woman asked a question saying um
that she you know she grew up with you
know conservative values but so many
people around her grew up with extremely
liberal values and one of the things
about that she said was that no one knew
what a soul was
no one knew what it meant to have a soul
an everlasting Soul an internal Soul
people thought that when they had issues
that she thought might be spiritual
issues and that we potentially growing
up you know people of my age group would
think were spiritual issues or things of
that nature people thought that they
were depression that they needed to take
drugs to fix it that they needed to be
medicalized that they needed psychiatric
care to fix these kinds of issues issues
like despair issues like depression
these are not just all issues that are
in your brain and so we have given away
religion we have given away culture we
have given away meaning
and we are expecting anybody to be able
to stand up on anything there's no
Foundation we burned it down we let them
burn it down and so and we handed them
the match Andy do you have any hope in
these uh lizard people calling
themselves politicians
uh no
I no they're not lizard people or I'm
being facetious obviously but but do you
have any hope in the current political
system where do you see things from your
perspective
I
I spend a lot of time outside the United
States now when I go back and or I pay
attention to things that are happening
here it it actually makes me really sad
like I I don't think it's a sign of a
vibrant democracy for people to show up
outside the homes of judges to try to
intimidate them uh impression them and
harass them into ruling in a certain way
that's actually uh I think a very
emblematic a decay in Liberal democracy
and
um all the issues we're talking about
here it's just um it's hard to be
optimistic
um it's hard to come up with like
Solutions it's almost at this point it's
kind of like it's
a certain line has already been passed
where uh any any solutions are maybe
just Band-Aids I don't know maybe I'm
being too pessimistic there
um
in responding to Libby I think the yes
the right the political right had
seated culture to the left and the left
I went Full Speed Ahead and you just
look at every every institution that
affects culture and it's
self-replicating they have power over
and it's significant so you know I think
even if the Republicans now were to take
up
um May 2020 Insurrection against uh the
White House it wouldn't have really any
currency to go far because there's no
media buy-in on that narrative and
I'm such a Critic of the media apparatus
for the fact that they can
uh create certain narratives and the
whole uphol narratives are untrue and
mislead the public and misinform them
and so it's uh yeah if you don't have
the support of that media infrastructure
you can you can rally around a claim it
won't go anywhere
yeah but I don't I don't if you look at
the big cable networks their viewership
is substantially less than Fox News and
like you know MSNBC CNN and HLN they get
less than what fox gets combined yes but
that that and in combination with print
Publications the they are able to make
the talking points that get to the desk
of those in Congress right my point
before was
Republicans will be sitting down with
Democrats and Democrats will say a b and
c and the Republicans go a b and c a b
and c when Republicans instead should be
going one two three
when the Democrats say 1 6 the
Republicans should only talk about May
29th so right now with the January 6
hearings Republicans should be having
their own hearings and any attempt at
any conversation on the house floor on
C-Span or otherwise should be on May
29th then the media won't have an option
so I mentioned it's similar to with
Donald Trump
he was on Twitter he should have gotten
parlor if he did it would have forced
the media to cover parlor and it would
have forced journalists to have signed
up for power to get access to his tweets
because the journalists set out right my
job requires me to have notifications
turned on for Trump's tweets that's
right but Trump wouldn't do it not until
after he's he's out of the news cycle
for the most part he's still here but
he's not the president what needs to
happen is Republicans need to stop
playing the game the Democrats are
required are demanding they play and the
Demers can come and say I've got a
health care bill and the Republicans
Republican should respond with uh thank
you for bringing it up yes on May 20th
there was an Insurrection and then
they're gonna be like we're having a
debate on a debate on what oh health
care right right the health care for
people on May 29th the president was
forced just do not give him a chance
they get a phone call from a New York
Times journalist and they say I'd like
to get your comments on this gun control
Bill ah yes yes on May 29th there was an
insurrection
and then they can print no comments or
they can choose to highlight the issue
so Republicans have power where they
want to acknowledge it or not and until
they decide to set the news cycle the
new cycle will be whatever Democrats
want to be I think the public are owed a
public inquiry about not just May 29
2020 but the months arrives from coast
to coast I tried my best to illuminate
just really one city in my book Portland
and there was dozens of other city that
experience recurring political violence
into to this day there's really been no
Congressional interests in finding out
who was before who was behind some of
these funding sources that were
channeling money to uh these pop-up
groups that were on GoFundMe and on cash
shop and venmo
who uh are part are part of these
networks that are helping transport
people from Portland to
um Louisville to
um other parts of the United States
um and the issue is the Republicans
actually don't want to challenge it
the the Democrats and the Democratic and
the Republican Party are the unit party
there was an Insurgency in 2016 Bernie
lost Trump won
Trump candidates ended up winning and
they didn't know how to stop him because
Trump was leading a lot of the party and
too many Republican voters were
unwilling to support someone like Mitt
Romney so now they're confused and
they're scared but I tell you this
Lindsey Graham and Mitch McConnell Kevin
McCarthy they would love
to be having a debate with the Democrats
over you know how much money to print or
you know on what day do we bomb children
is it the first or the second of the
month instead you get Trump who's like
Abraham Accords pulling our troops out
of the Middle East pulling our trips out
of Syria and showing up our borders and
they don't like that they canceled the
trans-pacific partnership too oh yeah
that pissed off Republicans and
Democrats yeah wrestling part of the
trans-pacific partnership this deal
where they wanted to get the United
States hooked on basically Malaysian oil
was called the investor State dispute
settlement and it would have gave these
Malaysian oil companies the ability to
sue the United States for discrimination
if we chose not to buy their oil and
then the American taxpayer would have
had to pay these corporations for for
discrimination and Bernie Sanders was
against it Trump came in and like on his
third day in office basically shut the
thing down well it was like NAFTA on
steroids but the the counter argument to
that is that there are rumors that this
deal was already dead and it didn't take
much not to go through with it because
the negotiations have failed I don't
believe that they redid the deal yeah I
did it with the all the other countries
reignited their own version of the deal
without the US it hasn't stopped them
before especially with NAFTA under Bill
Clinton which again pushes globalization
pushes multinational corporate interests
to have the way with the people and
that's essentially what they've been
doing for a very long time so what cloud
Schwab wanted right yeah operations
wants present tense yeah that's what he
wants I mean it's getting I would say
once and is succeeding at uh yeah we
were four a lot of people were forced
and manipulated to take a product that
they didn't want but if they wanted to
continue and live their lives normally
they had to and you know life hasn't
come back to normal and I I ever will I
disagree with that they didn't have to
it's only because they were too scared
that everybody ended up being having to
do something if you know if they come
out let me give this example
um you shouldn't speed speeding is
dangerous why does everybody speed it's
fun everybody no I'm in five miles over
it's still more fun than going it is
illegal to go even one mile an hour over
the limit but it's like a it's like a
it's like a slap on the wrist right you
get like a minor ticket yet you go on
the highway everyone's breaking the law
and for some reason they're not pulling
everyone over the reality is it's
because they can't right they only pull
over a couple of people the people who
are egregious and in red cars if
everyone breaks the law together then we
control what the law is it's like we
were talking about pedestrians earlier
but cops want everyone to go the same
speed let me let me give it to you a
better way it's not about breaking the
law it's about the law not being
culturally relevant because we've
mentioned this before there are books
that are called like wacky laws and it I
remember reading one where it's like in
Massachusetts it's illegal to put your
apple pie on your windowsill
but like that's ridiculous if you did
that no one's no cop is gonna walk up
and be like and the reason for it was
that back when Massachusetts was you
know tiny there you'd attract animals or
something right there's bills where it's
like you can't take showers on Tuesday
or Thursday and you can't water your
lawn on Monday Wednesday or Friday those
are California laws well those are now
but like on the east coast and it was
because the local water sources were
limited so they were like you can't do
these things but now these are not
culturally relevant and would never be
enforced right speed limits are weird
because they're kind of top-down
authoritarian and that like it'll say
every piece of this road is 65 miles an
hour even when you're turning and
dipping and turning when like well this
should be 45 sometimes you see signs at
night it should be slower at night if
it's raining it should be slower but the
signs always say the same number so you
have to make a judgment call that is
changing there are digital speed limit
signs now they change oh that's
interesting yeah and they can get hacked
watch out don't fall for the propaganda
when it says 108.99 yeah they're trying
to get you you know I feel like all this
it's like it says minimum 100 okay I'm
going too fast this propaganda the left
and the right and the Republican the
Democrat feels like a cult party game
and I'm looking at this Thomas Jefferson
quote I've been staring at it but uh
banking institutions are more dangerous
to our liberties than standing armies
and if you look at the last three or
four years I think this has played out
exactly where is the U.S military been
in this in the midst of this problem
they're not involved they're not messing
with us the National Guard's not giving
us problems it's Lo it's corporations
that are manipulating people with media
it's Black Rock things like these giant
conglomerate Reserve which gives them
these loans they use then buy up the
property from poor people it's it really
is and I think you know if we want to
revolt against anything it's against the
corporations it's against the bank you
know I think that you're onto something
with revolting against the corporations
because they also unleash all of this
wicked and ridiculous messaging all over
us that doesn't make any sense that
isn't even in line with what they're
doing you know it's that classic thing
the pride month all of the big companies
are like we're rainbow Super Rainbow
friendly we're covered in glitter in the
U.S Australia and England and Canada and
then you look at their their messaging
in North Africa and the Middle East and
China and there's there's no rainbow
glitter you know it's just the basic
plain logo they don't care about these
things they don't care about the values
that they're claim to claim to here's
the issue they just want to push them on
us and make us think that they believe
in these things and make us believe in
them too Corporation ruining the country
corporations are authoritarian yes so
that is correct with a constitutional
republic you know you have various
systems of of electing representative or
forms of governance but we have
guaranteed rights corporations have a
boss the boss says yes or no you want
money I can give it to you I can take it
away
so when Klaus Schwab is talking about
the world being governed by corporations
the the the morsel idea they try to
plant to people is oh we're talking
about people who do the work having say
over how the work gets done and what's
really happening is massively powerful
interests who can decide whether you get
access to resources or not they're
they're massively authoritarian they're
becoming more powerful than governments
themselves he wants the authoritarians
to take over yeah and we should be
careful to say corporations exactly
because I have a corporation you have a
corporation we all have our different
businesses these are these are people
who other corporations can't even
compete with because they're on such
another level they have bribed so many
politicians they have bought them off
they have the blackmail on so many
politicians that essentially they have
created a new kind of entity that is
even more powerful than the government
with how much uh money and power that
they're able to influence our everyday
lives over this is an important
distinction they're not corporations
anymore when something becomes a mega
Corp whatever you want to call it it's
not not it's not like a corporation like
we intended for it to be it's not a
person it's it's a it's a group of them
for instance and it's bigger than a
government I'm I can repeat everything
was just said but they need it it needs
a different word we can't take these
things seriously I'm just imagining like
you know back in the day with medieval
warfare you had groups of of similar
people
France and Britain right there they're
from the same area to the land now
like Warfare very much is major
corporations but just imagine thinking
like McDonald's private Army and things
like that you know it's like our chief
export is cheeseburgers and they have a
bunch of armed guards but it's like who
owns McDonald's probably BlackRock but
you think you think I'm kidding take a
look at the um the Banana Republic right
when armed guards went in and wanted to
make sure the bananas could be shipped
out because the bananas were the key you
know product for the company what was it
what was the company that Chiquita
Chiquita right and they like overthrew
the country yeah it's like the
government the corporation was more
powerful than the government look at the
stories and they had banana guards they
had banana police what happened with
Panama Noriega the stories of the
economic Hitman these are stories that
are absolutely mind-blowing to show you
how these multinational corporations use
uh intelligence agencies to do their
bidding for them I mean we reached such
a crazy level where again our government
is uh for purchase and it's been bought
by some really awful people who only
want to benefit themselves and and don't
care about anybody but they don't care
about you they buy it by buying the
corporations that work within the
government like I'm just looking at
McDonald's Corp the top three investment
holders are Vanguard group State Street
and BlackRock they own about 19 of
McDonald Court you would nailed it it
was BlackRock the other thing too these
corporations think that because they are
so big because they have amassed so much
money and and economic power that is up
to them to influence government policy
we saw this in Florida with Disney
coming after the laws in that state
believing that they had some sort of
right to tell Ron DeSantis and the
legislature and all of the people of
Florida that they couldn't have this
parental rights and education Bill even
though it was wildly popular and
corporations came out just recently a
whole bunch of them all got together and
sent a letter saying hey we demand
action on gun control it's it's
important that we say something we have
to take a stand and say something shut
up like shut up you go make money we
already give you a ton of money we buy
your stupid stuff we eat your stupid bad
cheeseburgers you know you don't get a
say over the government that we elected
maybe each individual does write a
letter to your Congressman write a
letter to your representative what have
you like you're an individual
constituent but the corporations that
believe that they have a right to
influence the federal government to
influence the state governments and it's
such a huge
um overreach on their part yeah and you
said it earlier you thought this was
intentional what's happening I think so
because there's nothing more that these
people would love to see than the fall
of American Democratic Republic It's the
biggest then they will get to take over
they will just get to do whatever they
want what's your favorite Corporation
Andy
uh I don't think I have one but this I
mean this conversation I gosh I haven't
put enough thought into thinking about
uh the power the relationship between
corporations and government and I'm I'm
embarrassed that I'm ignorant about that
I just and as Libby was channeling her
anger just now you know it's it's made
me so angry and frustrated so like yeah
why why is Ben and Jerry's uh and all
these other
sjw corporations and trying to affect
legislation in the UK benageres is
trying to pressure the British
government uh against its um
uh legislation about uh sending a
illegal Asylum Seekers to Rwanda and
it's yeah but I think the case in
Florida of a corporation that's
headquartered in Burbank California
trying to tell
parents what they can or cannot have
um in in terms of information about the
children's education that's like but out
I'm surprised that there aren't more
people pushing back you're right that
there does seem to just sort of we just
lay down and accept that we accept this
culture where these Mega corporations
with their billions and billions of
dollars can actually try to influence
our laws and this is mostly
inappropriate trillions this used to be
a left-wing position
um and now we're talking about it well
that's because the corporations uh took
all of the
um you know took all of the tax breaks
and whatever whatever else from the GOP
and then just sided with the leftists
anyway
I'm trying to look is it Unilever that
owns Ben and Jerry's
is that can anyone confirm that I'm not
sure I'm not sure I think it's a
Unilever I'm not Jerry's uh I'm gonna
try Ben and Jerry's and Dove are both
owned by Unilever so I wonder who owns
Unilever no Unilever is the parent
company yeah but Oh you mean the
investors yeah who invests oh come on
you know I have an idea Black Rock State
Street and Van they own like 18 to 19 of
almost every corporation in the world
every publicly traded Corp Microsoft uh
Dow you you go down the list it is
embarrassing that I didn't know it's
embarrassing for me that I wasn't aware
of this until two years ago well I think
it's probably just good that you're
aware of it now yeah thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there